- But, um,
I'm really good at hand-eye coordination
so I'll be naturally gifted at it.
- [Man] So you're
feeling pretty confident.
- Yeah, I can see him
running away in trouble.
(upbeat, hip-hop music)
About to fuckin' destroy Agassi's face.
- [Man] Okay, standing by.
- [Man] Agassi, Agassi,
for the first time.
- Well, if all else fails, my
old friend, the Soviet Union.
(fun, game music)
Yeah!
Good job, D-Rock.
I mean even those shots at
goal were not even close.
You did only lose, four
three, I'm impressed with you.
- Really good game, it happened.
- We don't celebrate losing, D-Rock.
- I know you're out of schedule.
- No worries.
- So we're gonna try
to get you on there.
- No worries, don't, don't,
Don't over swear it.
- [Man] Rock n' Roll, Christine.
- [Man] Wow.
- [Woman] This is a pretty exciting game.
I can tell you now, last week,
when I reached out to the...
- [Man] Excellent.
- Wow.
I wanna win, yeah, like I actually wanna,
like I feel like we can, it's
a totally different game.
- Yeah, I gotta try and watch some.
- It's got ping pong-esque things to it,
which I think will help me.
- That makes sense.
- We just need highlights for the blog.
- A hundred percent.
- We just need an animated gif
of you passing Veronica on the base line.
- Now that realize that I have the chance
to be on the same side
of Andre and not you,
I kinda wanna do that.
- No, you don't wanna.
Dumb finish, that's it.
Well, why don't you let
Andre run purel with you.
If I can get people
to buy into the strategy, and then, watch.
To me, the perfect storm
is understate my religion,
and then copy everything I do.
I start a podcast, you start a podcast.
I start doing more
filters, you start doing.
Why am I doing less hashtags on Instagram,
not for my fuckin' health.
Like, like, get my mindset
and then do exactly what I'm doing.
- [Man] Yeah.
- I'm playing picket ball?
You go play picket ball.
(laughter)
- Andre.
- Such a pleasure.
- Thank you.
- Real pleasure, how are you?
- I'm wonderful, wonderful.
- Good, Gary.
- Come on in.
- Yeah, thanks.
This is Ryan.
- How you doin'?
- [Ryan] Ryan, how are you? I'm a big fan.
- How's it going?
- Yeah, how are you?
- Good to see you.
- How are you, man?
Hey, Amir?
So really nice...
You've never played this?
- I've played it once.
- Once.
- Like, but I don't know,
it was like two years ago.
- Yeah, about three, well...
- Two or three years ago.
It's been awhile.
- Andre, have you ever played this?
- No.
- Ever?
- Ever.
- Have you?
- No.
(laughing)
- I've never even heard
of the sport until now.
- It's massive.
- Like literally.
- It's exploding.
- It's massive.
- Born ready.
- Not ready, not ready.
- [Announcer] It's time for the,
in the history of their lives...
- [Man] Not that, partner.
(balls bouncing)
That's a great shot!
- Ah.
- Oh, that's out!
- Wow, wow, wow, wow.
- Oh, I got this.
- Yeah!
(balls bouncing)
- Ah.
Gary, stop taking the ball from...
Have you ever seen the movie Hitch?
- Yeah.
- Okay, where he tells him
to dance and just stay in
his lane, like right here.
- I'll stand right here.
- This is you.
This is you, and this is me.
(grunting)
- [Man] Oh.
(yelling)
(balls bouncing)
- Yes!
- Guys, stop calling!
(cheering and grunting)
(groans)
- [Announcer] To Agassi.
(balls bouncing)
(cheering)
- [Man] Stay with it Ford!
- [Announcer] Ford, get off the court!
(balls bouncing)
- [Announcer] That's it, that's in!
- [Man] Ooh.
(groans)
(balls bouncing)
Ooh.
- [Announce] Sharp battle, baby.
- [Man] Ooh.
(cheering)
- Kill it!
(balls bouncing)
- [Man] Ooh.
- [Announcer] Can he just
say that was the closest
he'd ever been to the net?
But anyway, it's an illegal shot.
(balls bouncing)
(cheering)
(groaning)
(balls bouncing)
- [Man] Ooh.
- [Announcer] The score is nine, eight.
Team Roddick.
(balls bouncing)
(cheering)
- [Announcer] An out of
bounds shot right there.
- [Man] Violation!
- [Announcer] Makes the score...
(paddle thumps)
(balls bouncing)
(audience softly yelling)
- [Man] No!
(laughing)
- Yes!
(soft clapping)
- Win by one.
- Wait, it's win by one?
This is it?
- [Man] Do or die, Gary!
(balls bouncing)
(groaning)
(cheering)
(laughing)
- He used all of his
composure in his career.
(cheering)
(laughter)
- Touchdown.
- Oh, thank you.
(cheering)
- My guy.
- You the man, brother.
- Thank you, my man. I appreciate that.
- Love it, bro.
- Appreciate it.
- Good to see you.
Take care, guys. Stay well.
- You too.
- Thank you.
I think you and I as a team
can dominate these things
at such a high level so...
(car engines roar)
- Awesome, thanks, so long.
- Thank you.
- Appreciate it.
- How you doin', man?
- Good, man, how are you?
- How you doin', brother?
What's up, man, how are you?
Good.
- Welcome.
- What's up, thank you, guys.
Thank you, hello.
Hi.
- Hey!
- Excuse me?
- Ralph Baker.
- Your father-in-law's Ralph Baker?
- Yeah.
- That's so awesome!
Tell him I said hi.
Small businesses in the south,
get ready, we fuckin' find...
How many years in Chandrika?
- Two and a half.
- Two and a half years in,
we fuckin' unlocked it, get
ready, offerings are coming.
Let's fucking go.
- The 30 second story is
you go to the grocery store
to get a loaf of bread.
It's been on the shelf 10, 14 days.
Hostess is trying to make it 60 days.
You don't know what it is.
Come to the store where
this is on the floor,
you can have that hot loaf
of bread to take home.
- Can I ask you a question?
- Yeah.
- Is this available yet?
Hey, D-Rock?
- [D-Rock] Yeah.
- Alright, we gotta run to the...
- Yeah.
- South by, if you're too
structured, you're fucked.
- I like your beanie.
- I've never looked better.
- Thank you.
Hi.
(cheering)
- Just shout out.
- [Woman] What's the
worst advice you've given?
(audience laughs)
- Monica, wait for your time.
- That's a good question.
I can answer it while
you're thinking about it.
I think the worse
- I'm just slower in reaction.
- I think the worse advice I give
is when I make it
through the eyes and ears
and filter of who I am as a person.
I think way too many people give advice
predicated on themselves.
A lot of the things I look for are themes,
but I spend a lot more time looking
at the collective than myself
because there's of nuances about me
that doesn't map for other people.
So I think way too many
people's advice is too singular,
and they don't have empathy to understand
the subtleties of
everybody else around them.
(audience clapping)
See you guys.
Love you.
- Thank you.
Alright, sir.
- Take it, bye.
- [Man] Ten years, bro, it's
been a legacy play for me.
- The thought of fuckin'
going to do business here
just because of fucking capital gains
is not fuckin' smart, period.
- He's maybe a little more...
- Extreme?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, to me, it's just
about value exchange.
It's just reputation.
- Brother, my name's Stefan.
- Stefan, real pleasure.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- Thank you so much.
- Sir, can I get a picture?
- You sure can.
- Real quick, sorry.
- Take care guys, stay well.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice meetin' you, my man.
Hope to see you in New York, alright?
Take care of yourself,
congrats on everything.
- I'll see you in May.
- [Man] Hi, Gary!
- Hello.
How are you?
- Great.
- Good to see you.
- Let me tell you what's
gonna happen today,
we're gonna have five
companies who are pitching.
They're gonna give two
minute elevator pitch,
and then they get six minutes
of Q and A with the judges.
We're gonna have them
bring out each company.
You guys will go into it,
there's a clock right there.
I just wanna give us a time
frame of what's happening.
- A beast right now.
- What's up?
- A beast.
- Just giving him
His guide, he never stops.
- Do what he says.
- He never stops.
(laughing)
- You too, how you doing?
- Is it on, is your mic on, my mic's on.
Do you want my mic, do you
wanna borrow it, get in there.
- Ashton Kutcher, thank you.
- Thank you, how are you?
- Alright, here's the deal.
Here are the quick few ground rules.
We have five amazing, brave entrepreneurs
who are gonna come up
here for two minutes.
(soft, piano music)
- My man, you're important,
you're important.
We need people to look
at, we need fuckin',
you saw, what's his name,
Peele say the other day,
I mean I haven't seen the Oscars.
You know about this, right?
He's like, he gave Whoopi
Goldberg a shout out, he's like,
"I was a little boy, and I
watched you win an academy award.
"And I was, and I was
like then I can do it."
Like that's real, like it's real.
Like there's so many kids
that struggle in school,
and like, I need to be
out there and be like,
"Look, we gotta see people
and like, you know."
- [Man] And people want that.
- Yeah, it's just
important, it's important.
If you're a big, heavyset
black dude in fuckin' Alabama,
16 right now, and you're fuckin' smart,
it's nice to know it's true.
- Yep.
- And then my big thing is,
like I'll be honest with you.
My big thing is if I do this for you,
and I sit down and chop it
up and break bread with you,
then when Tyrone Thompson from
Kent, Kansas, hits you up,
I'm hopin' that it
subconsciously, not even like,
not you bein' like, "Oh, Gary did it."
Just subconsciously, you're like, "Yes."
- [Man] People wait 'til they,
peoples, they wait 'til they win, like,
"I'm gonna wait 'til I win,
and then I'm gonna give back."
(soft, piano music)
What I like about you, Gary,
is that you've documented this process
all the way from library TV,
you can follow the process,
and you do what you say
you finna freakin' do.
There's so many people that talk,
they don't frickin' do nothing.
- [Gary] My biggest thing is it's,
and Phil will tell you this,
Phil knows me very well.
Probably, it's really funny
to have Phil and D-Rock here,
they know me well, for different reasons.
My big thing is I often
talk about things I've done
more than things I'm gonna do.
And when I say I'm gonna do things,
one of the things I do poorly is
I run my mouth like everybody else.
It's just that then I
fuckin' take the L, like I,
Phil will tell you, I don't
think people would understand
how many bad deal business things I do.
It's cause I ran my mouth,
and it matters more to deliver
on what I said than, right?
- [Phil] Yeah.
- [Gary] My great
vulnerability in the micro...
- [Phil] Yeah.
- [Gary] Is that I say
yes too much, right?
- [Phil] Which is shit, man, quite a bit.
- [Gary] Which is shit that
I've gotten better, right?
That was smart, that was fuckin'
awesome, you can email me.
You can email me, I fuckin' loved that.
- For our own pitches, and
I'm like, we're about ready.
- I'm like, yeah, I'm just like
cleaning up, like, yes, yes.
- Oh, I'll see ya, let's
go, let's go, let's go.
- But it's in that yes
that also makes me different and special,
like there's people who are gonna beat me.
They'll make more money.
I'm not built to make the
most money, but motherfucker,
there's no entrepreneur that's given back
to the game like me.
And I don't mean like, "Here's
a million dollars for my name
"on the fuckin' school
for entrepreneurship."
That means dipshit, that means
I feel good and I'm cool.
Like, that's fuckin ego.
I'm givin' back with the
fuckin' thing that matters most:
my time, my heart, and my fuckin' head.
(soft, piano music)